the eighth and final season of Game of
Thrones has finally arrived in the
episode titled Winterfell
we get a ton of references to the very
first episode of the series which
premiered way back in 2011 here are 13
details you might have missed from
season 8 episode 1 and of course warning
spoilers are coming right at the top of
the new episode we get new visuals
accompanying the theme song what's
probably most important to note is that
the northern wall now has a giant hole
reminding us of the season 7 finale
where the undead reanimated Viserion
obliterates the wall we also get three
new panels showing the fall of the wall
the red wedding and Daenerys dragons
being born at the beginning of the
episode we see Daenerys and Jon Snow
entering Winterfell with the large army
and two dragons this procession mirror
season 1 episode 1 when Robert Baratheon
arrived at Winterfell to make Ned Stark
hand of the king
not only did the two scenes look similar
but both scenes also share the exact
same music
[Music]
the boy pushing the crowd and climbing
is similar to both bran and Aria
speaking of Aria just like season 1
episode 1 she catches a glimpse of the
hound but they've got a lot more history
now the boy in this scene at the meeting
of the northern Lords is Lord Ned umber
who we saw last season pledging fealty
to how stark knows who is Ned he's the
son of small john number who died at the
Battle of the bastards if you watched
the episode then you know this isn't the
last we see of the boy but before we get
there we should explain where exactly
tormund barrack and the others are
treading carefully at the end of the
episode well they're actually at last
hearth which is south of the wall but
north of Winterfell and that's where the
umbers live at last hearth Bera kills
the reanimated Ned umber with his
flaming sword illuminating a spiral
pattern we've seen this pattern before
back in season 3 we saw the body parts
of dismembered nights Watchmen and
horses we saw the pattern again in
season 5 when the children of the forest
created the night king and then again in
season 7 in the cave drawings at
Dragonstone we still don't know get its
significance but clearly it's an
important sign of the White Walkers in
another nod to season 1 John and arias
reunion in this episode is a close a
mirror of when John and Arya said
goodbye in season 1 episode 2 they hug
in a near identical way and that's when
John gave Arya needle her beloved sword
in this episode John notices that Arya
still has the blade
we see John fly a dragon for the first
time which is certainly momentous but
there's actually more going on here the
dragon John flies is Ragle named after
his real father Rhaegar Targaryen in the
season 8 trailer we saw this same scene
but John was not in the shot this scene
is no doubt a reference to when John
made love to his first love Ygritte in a
cave near a waterfall according to the
creators this location in season 8 is
also where John would have hunted when
he was younger
Arya meets ginjury and hands him a
drawing of a new weapon she wants him to
make out of dragonglass in the season 2
trailer we see Arya with a new dagger
which could be what she's asking ginjury
to make for her in this episode ginjury
and Arya reunite ginjury calls arya lady
Stark
- which Arya replies don't call me that
ginjury then replies as you wish milady
this is a direct mirror of a
conversation they had in season 2
episode 2 I should be called a new
milady do not call me milady
as Brady commands tyrion says because of
john's courage they have brought the
greatest army the world has ever seen
this is similar to a phrase Mance Rayder
says back in season 3 mance was talking
about lighting a fire to alert the
wildlings that it was time to attack
Castle black in the scene with bran
Qyburn gives bran a crossbow the weapons
sir she wants Bronn to use to kill her
traitor brothers this is significant
because you may remember that Tyrion
uses a crossbow to kill their father
Tywin Lannister
midway through the episode Sam finds
brand and brand says he's waiting for an
old friend we find out later the old
friend he's referring to is Jaime
Lannister who shows up at Winterfell
Jaime pushed bran out a window back in
season 1 leading to the injury that left
him unable to walk the things I do for
love
so there you have it do we miss anything
let us know in the comments
[Music]